today's guest we've been uh waiting on
and we're happy that she's able to
uh finally put it in park long enough to
come and be here with us
she is female trucker
and that interstate bad girl
ginger
[Music]
[Applause]
what type of uh what type of like halls
will you be on now so
how long have you been doing trucking
and then what type of halls will you be
on
i've been doing it for about nine years
now almost nine
march i think okay and uh we haul just
about everything from like uh
woodford whiskey oh yeah i love whiskey
too who am i used to
um we might haul uh scott's miracle grow
dirt
oh yeah just depends on who's calling
for what
you know so we host a lot of aak which
is
like edible oils oil flakes or the oil
in the bottles or
the hardened grease like the lard stuff
we deliver it to places that use it for
baking and cooking oh wow really yeah so
you'll deliver to our like places in the
midwest kind of or no we're mostly east
okay all the east coast so what's the
longest haul that you'll go out on like
whenever you get your
you work for uh you're a subcontractor i
guess
no i just work for the company you know
just an employee there
and i don't own any of the equipment
okay just keep it nice so it you know it
looks good
parents-wise but uh basically
every truck it's they've all been good
trucks they you know they haul
good stuff you know it's not nothing
that we've hauled that's been
nasty or bad we do haul some carbide on
flatbeds but i ain't messing with that
and what is that it's a it's a chemical
that's explosive if it's wet so do you
get paid more if you're hauling
something like that oh yeah
yeah cause that's a hazardous material
that you're hauling
you have to have an endorsement on your
license to do that
so and they'll adjust the plates like on
the back of the trucks a lot of times
you'll see those plates you bring those
up
those are placards okay and so what are
those what are those plate what does
that mean what are those
it's different types of flammables
explosives uh
corrosives whether it's gas or fem
you know fumes or say if it's if it gets
wet
it could be explosive so it depends on
what the material is
and who adjusts those plates like do you
adjust those yeah these are the ones
right here yeah
so yeah the like do you have all of
those plates on your car and they're all
on your rig and they're all adjustable
or you only have some of those how does
that work they're like uh say you got
one
of the diamonds and it turns like cards
so you can pick the one you need and
you'll latch it to where that it'll show
what's
what it is an oxidizer or you know it's
a
organic peroxide or radioactive or
poison it it'll have that on there
i see so it's all built into there yeah
yeah and you legal do you adjust this or
does the company whenever you take off
with the load how does that work
we find out what it is that we're
hauling first
and they usually explain it on your
bills bill of ladings and then it'll
tell you what
to put on there which which placards you
have to have because you got
to have it shown in four places which is
the trailer
the both sides and the doors because
d.o.t will pull you over right oh yeah
they get happy with that [ __ ] they they
sometimes they get bored
oh looking for i had an [ __ ] one time
pulling into a weigh station literally
and he's standing out there first time
i've ever seen this
and he kind of looks like a just this
little short [ __ ]
like elmer yeah he's thumping
everybody's tires as you're pulling in
i was like okay i'm cool you know i'm
good comes up to me
and what is he doing hitting them for
what seeing if there's cocaine like
drugs in them to make sure that they're
aired up oh okay
well i guess what i had a [ __ ] flat
no yeah
drive tire didn't even know it what
happened was as i was pulling in i ran
over a freaking bolt as big as my thumb
oh damn so it wasn't even hot yet
because when i pulled in and he's you
know he's showing me
the tires wiggling off the rim and i'm
sitting there just ready to just scream
so i was like [ __ ] you know hell
here you know and he's like well you
can't leave till you get it fixed
so i'm calling the shop and i'm letting
them know what's going on and
one of them throws a fit one of the guys
you work for yeah i was like what am i
supposed to do
you know radar every damn thing on the
road today yeah i didn't see it
next time i'll i'll dodge the nails and
bolts you gotta bolt at 12
20. yeah now but got it fixed and rolled
on
they they didn't give me no ticket or
nothing you know they can be [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah definitely and do you find
a lot of uh
a lot of the officers and stuff that you
encounter out there a lot of them are
men or women was it kind of mixed out
there
what the police officers they're mostly
men yeah
mostly men and do they give you you
think a different type of like a
different type of
interaction because you're a female or
no you think it's mixed
because i actually got pulled over in
sellersburg indiana
i had a woman in front of me kept
hitting her brakes and
when you're in the truck and you're
doing 65 miles an hour
maybe 67 you know you don't want to be
behind somebody that don't know where
the hell they're going
yeah you run right over top of them
speed bump you know
and uh like in mario kart yeah oh [ __ ]
and uh anyways i'm
you know keep getting up on her ass and
i'd back off
you know she'd stop and i'd get on her
ass again and back off
and we're all rolling it's kind of busy
we're coming around this uh
i guess you call it like the cross over
there the bridge like
there's a cop sitting there and i had
just changed lanes to keep from hitting
this woman
into the hammer lane what is the hammer
lane that's the fast lane
okay you know you're in the middle lane
and i went to go avoid her and when i
went back into the middle lane he's seen
it
he pulls me over and i was like how are
you looking when he pulls you over
you're looking pretty good
i was trying to maintain i'm like hi how
are you you know come on in and have a
seat you know
agreeing and [ __ ] and then he's telling
me what i did and i was like yeah i said
i was trying not to hit her
i said she kept hitting her brakes and
he's like i seen that
i was like okay you've seen it so what's
going on this ain't bumbling oh you know
the lips starting to curl and
yeah he's like well you know you was in
the wrong lane
trucks are not allowed in the hammer
lanes you can't go in the fast lane
and he was following too close plus she
was doing 67 but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna get you for that but is
that true that you can't what do you
mean you can't go in the fast and you're
supposed to stay in the right lane
trucks are not allowed
in the passing lane in the fast lane
it's usually the middle
or the slow lane so that's if there's
three lanes right
okay now first two lanes you can go in
either one okay but if there's three
you're not supposed to get into the far
left lane
no ever no i actually got a ticket
ticket
not a warning a ticket in bartow georgia
did you deserve it was my father's in
that damn lane yeah amen
yeah it's hard to do but at the same
time there was an [ __ ]
volvo driver okay he's in the middle
lane story in my life
he's driving up the hill right he's
taking his deers taking his time dude
yeah slow probably america trading on
his family i'm getting pissed yeah
and i was like well you know what i was
like [ __ ] this and i got over
and got in the hammer lane started
flying up the hill right well this
pecker head decides he's gonna speed up
so we're both racing nose to nose up his
heel we get top of the hill or sit a
state trooper
in the median lights immediately go on i
looked over at that fat guy i wanted to
shoot him in the face
i was just aggravated i was like [ __ ] so
i knew he was coming as soon as i seen
him lights come on i was like okay
that's it i'm done yeah so i backed off
i let the fat man go
i got over into the slow lane in the
shoulder cop comes over he's a younger
guy he's all buff and big and he's got
an attitude
because he opens the door and he's
looking at me like well
you're going to say something or what
and i was like
he's like you know why i pulled you over
i said yeah probably because i was in
that damn hammer lane over there
and uh he goes yeah yeah it's clearly
marked that trucks are not allowed i
said i bet i was trying to
pass that fat guy in the volvo
he didn't care hell no he wrote you up
he wrote me a ticket
he's like you gotta pay this and uh i
called him the day
that i got the ticket and i was like can
i go ahead and pay this now
and get it all you know get it off my
back and no it's not even in the
computer yet honey you're gonna have to
wait
isn't that so ridiculous like you gotta
wait nine and they try to get you i
think she'll forget about it kind of
yeah so they can find you some more yeah
yeah you got to wait take your license
one time they told me you got to wait
till it snows you can't pay it till it
snows outside i'm like what in the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
does that got to do with anything yeah i
need to pay this damn give [ __ ] what
it's doing outside
i want to pay this we got a question
from uh a caller right here this isn't
live just so you know this is a video
someone sent in let's uh
let's take this question here for ginger
what up theo
this past weekend uh what up female
trucker guest wanted to ask do you ever
cut people off out of revenge
um i see it all the time on the road
i feel bad you guys get cut off a lot
my wife's cut you guys off she felt bad
about it
but uh yeah we know there's a lot of
road rage especially here in california
central valley california we love you
over here by the way
um but yeah do you cut people off out of
revenge
gang gang honk honk there you go ginger
you're on the hot seat
straight up honest about that i've
wanted to
you know and there's times when it's
like you know i'm gonna show you
oh it's some little rich [ __ ] in a
dance oh no sometimes it's other
semi-trucks a damn lexus
yeah whatever and it gets kind of scary
sometimes and
oh it's other semis yeah it's cars as
well semi trucks
it's not like it used to be so the
because when i was growing up i always
felt like there was a strong sense of
camaraderie you know i grew up
in my neighborhood everybody had like a
uh a ham radio you know or a tran what
is it called
cb like a cb radio yeah
date men that had cbs and so we always
had cbs around everybody in our
neighborhood had a cb in their car
yeah so sometimes if you weren't doing
anything you just go sit in your car
and just talk to people going by on the
interstate uh it's it's not like it no
more
and you would see it would seem like
there was a lot of camaraderie between
the truckers out there it's
it's not you could know you could
actually be coming up on traffic
it's stopping by bumper to bumper all
you see is brake lights
and you'll get on the radio and be like
hey has anybody got their ears on let me
know what's going on up there
well can't you read the goddamn sign it
was only about 10 miles back
and it's like shut the [ __ ] up
i just asked a simple question you you
know and yeah it starts getting heated
really yeah yeah and i told jeffrey i
said my son
i got the benefit you know it's like you
i've been in the truck before and
honestly be holding a steering wheel
and turn it off oh you can just shut it
down
have to listen to you [ __ ] i'm turning
this thing off you know
and it's it's the people are rude you
know just
rude so there's not a sense of
camaraderie there's not as much of a
sense it's almost cut throat
anymore and i didn't see that when i was
a kid when my dad was driving
because back then we were allow his kids
me and my two brothers
we would climb in the back seat of the
or the back bed of the pickup truck
ride down i-65 to dean's lake in indiana
go swimming and stuff and get back in
this you know the pickup and
ride back you know do all this to all
these trucks you know hey
it was part of life yeah you don't
hardly see that anymore
and then people cutting you off all the
time but no you got to think of it my
teacher told me this when i was in
school
every vehicle whether it's a semi a car
motorcycle whatever picture little kids
in it
so that that gets drilled in your head
like it's almost like a mental picture
you have
right off the bat but if them little
kids [ __ ] if they're on their kids
oh yeah i've seen them you know
you know and and like pick their nose
throw boogers that you know
date it can be mean but most of the time
the little kids are just got the little
fist going
you know and they're just laying on i've
scared the [ __ ] out of bus drivers
oh yeah that's fun it is yeah what kind
of bus are you talking we talking
greyhound are we talking school bus
oh yeah anybody could do with little
kids you got a whole row of little kids
all grinning at you
staring out the window you're riding
right alongside of them you know
and you're a woman too so little kids
you know kind of just little little more
yeah and i'm just giving that horn hell
you know entertaining them and the whole
time the bus driver's like
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was like oh sorry sorry you know going
past her waving
and then finally she right up alongside
of you she toot her horn oh yeah
yeah the kids are having a ball so do
some trucks have better horns than
others actually
let's go to this question we got a
question right here that came in from a
fella that's staying safe
what's up theo vaughn's brother mound
real nick davis this is jordan from up
in portland sorry about the face mask my
server is about to be here to take my
order um i got a question for the truck
driver
this signal here do you recognize that i
was a kid we used to
do it all the time to get the semi-truck
drivers to honk their horns do you see
that
anymore i haven't really seen kids doing
that these days i haven't done it so
let me know thank you for your service
appreciate you gang gang
gang yeah we don't see a lot of uh i'm
not on the roads that much
right so when i used to drive to comedy
club you know have to drive around to
them and stuff i would be on the roads a
lot
you know so i'm not on the roads as much
but that's a good question do you still
see it
sometimes yeah and i've actually had
adults that have rolled along young
adults
that have rolled up alongside of me and
get me to do that and they'll start
clapping and they're
all yeah yeah that's like yeah just
reliving their past a little yeah i
guess
that or just you know like actually like
to hear the air horns blow
yeah because it's a lot different than
the city horn it's two tubes
so so there's different so you have
different horns in there two
okay take me through that one's an air
horn that's the string one that you pull
okay is it a real string what does it
look like yeah it's a string
okay and it just pulls it i guess it
releases from the
the uh will you call them hydraulics
yeah and then it just blows through and
it creates like a train
sound it sounds like a train engine okay
oh
it's cool um how many are there a lot of
women out there in the sport
or no i've seen more since i was a kid
but it's still like a 50 to 1 ratio
it's still over you know it's it's men
dominated
that's just the way it is you're going
to do it you're going to have to blend
in with them
you have to and what does that mean when
you say blend in with them
well do you mind the story no a little
story yeah i got time for it
example to blend in you would take
you know like uh things that they say
as insults cry about it get upset you
know okay
kind of pucker up like a girl you know
mousey why did you say that
what there's no room for that right
there's not and you know i'm walking up
to the truck stop and i was getting fuel
i wanted to get some coffee so
i walk in and this big guy opens up the
door for me and he's like nice tits
and i looked over at him and i was like
nice tits
and i walked in he had bigger boobs and
i did
he had some freaking heaters on him huh
yeah i have to do that
to like i'm walking out with hot dogs
and this guy's like you want to come in
and see my hot dog i got a hot dog for
you hey
and i was like well you shut the hell up
i said i'm gonna go eat my lunch before
i throw up on it
and then just went to my truck and ate
my hot dogs yeah
then that part of it's obviously that's
messed up but at the same time part of
it is kind of funny
yeah a little bit it is funny and you
people watch a lot too when especially
when you're sitting you got 10-hour
break
you can drive 14 hours 11 of that's
driving three hours is
on duty not driving okay so what does
that mean take me through some of that
so
so the rule is you can drive for how
long 11 hours
11 hours straight no no yeah you can
drive
up to eight but before the h you have to
take a 30 minute break
okay before they once you took your 30
minute break it'll reset it
to where that you've got extra time to
drive and you usually approximately have
maybe
four to five more to drive and you're
done and it can't total any more than
14.
that's on duty not driving is usually
like
fueling washing your truck windshield
off or any repairs that might be needed
that's on duty okay and so you'll take
so you might drive seven hours
and there's five hours and then say okay
i'm gonna take my half hour break yes
i'm gonna take a half hour break now yes
and then how much more can you drive for
you take another break
uh you'll only be allowed maybe five
maybe six
more just depends on you know how you
run before
and once once that happens you have to
take a 10-hour break
okay so i'm just going to just because
i'm not good at a lot so i'm going to
ask again
just so out of 14 hours
you can only drive 11 of them right and
then after that 14-hour space
right you have to take a 10-hour break
yes okay so within 14 hours you need to
take three hours break
yes total total and then after that you
you need to take a 10-hour break yes
okay and do you is that good because you
you're glad to have the breaks or is it
bad because you're trying to make time
no when you take your 30 minute break
that's it's actually
you know you can break any time you want
actually
like sometimes i'll stop after i've
drove about four hours
and i'll take a 15 minute break just to
stretch my legs get out
walk you know maybe get a drink or pee
and then get back in the truck you drive
another say
three and a half more hours before the
eight's up and i'll take
a 30. that's when i'll have my lunch or
i'll play a video game on my phone
or just you know just walk around
anything
oh because before eight hours you have
to also take a break yeah
yeah you have to okay that's the law
required it has to be a 30-minute break
okay so with that within every 14 hours
you can only drive 11.
right and every eight hours you have to
take a break yes
i got it yes then once you pull over for
the night
and it's time to take your 10-hour break
you can rest area or truck stop there's
times when
i've pulled over onto a ramp you know as
you're getting
back on the interstate that way when i
wake up i can just
take off keep it and go yeah a lot of
times yeah you will see trucks that are
just right there on the side i always
wonder what's going on
i usually thought sex or drugs
no not for me i'll uh pull my curtains i
got the truck running up to set my
temperature where i want it
you know especially like in i like the
ac on so i'll dim all my lights inside
and make sure my doors are locked and
depending on the area sometimes i'll
actually like use my seat belt
latch it over the door handle and lock
it so they can't you can't open the door
no matter what you do
yeah and then once that you get back
here you pull the curtain
pull back my covers i got my microwave i
got a keurig for coffee
i got a tv set up in there put dvds in
it or i've got a cord that hooks up to
my
iphone and i watch movies oh wow yeah i
got home movies in a little cabinet that
i can watch and
i'll sit back here and eat you know
smoke cigarette watch tv
and set my alarm go to bed that's it
and so now are there times that you will
no so i'm guessing that your truck has a
facility of space in there you can get
some rest oh yeah
plenty it's actually got uh bunk beds in
there okay
the bottom one is uh uh like a full to
twin
can you pull that up for us on
freightliner cabin or what would we
bring up you think what we
oh just a inside cab freightliner
and uh look up maybe bunk or sleeper
berth
that actually would be better look up
sleeper berth
and it'll show you this because you got
a bed up the top that you can fold back
against the wall
if you're not using it so it leaves that
space open for you
or you could pull it down if you had
somebody with you and you stop you
let them hang out up there and sleep but
you don't put them up there while you're
driving
right because they could actually fall
out yeah that sounds a little risky now
which one of these you think seems like
yours here ginger
okay that's see the band with the red
yeah
that's kind of it's kind of like that
inside okay
because it's got the bunk beds and it's
got cabinet space
and then i've got a spot for the
microwave
refrigerators right underneath of it oh
yeah yeah it's it's nice you got enough
room
that's where i actually learned to dance
for his uh wedding
was in my truck really yeah i couldn't
be with him to
me and him to learn the dance together
so i
practiced inside of my truck so jeff
sent you a video and showed you how to
do it well
it was part of the movie uh pulp fiction
oh wow
where john travolta and uh uh what's her
name
what's her name [ __ ] karen she was it
was uh
yeah uma thurman thurman yeah when they
danced together
in that restaurant they were at that's
what me and him is mother and son for
his wedding
yeah so you learned that in your tricks
you could stand up and learn that oh
yeah there's enough room in that cab to
do that
and so now there's a lot of oh yeah
there it is right there that's cool
that's awesome and i was learning that
in the truck because most of it is
just a twist so you're not flailing
yourself all over the place you know you
could get hurt in there
yeah yeah i can imagine that yeah for
some for people that don't know uh
your son is jeff right and he's been he
came in the podcast a while back breasty
jeff right and he had
long i guess just some extra meat on his
breast yeah yeah
yeah i hate it for him but hell man
pretty cool really kind of you know in
some ways but a really great guy and
he's kept in touch with the podcast and
it was awesome that he just kind of uh
he's like oh i know a woman who'll be
perfect for this yeah he told me about
it
and i was just ecstatic i was like
really me
you know because you kind of like the
the like you feel like the little kid at
the school somebody picked me
it's me cool it's cool yeah my mama's uh
my mom delivers now just for amazon and
but she's always been like a hard worker
you know always been
yeah you know did her own thing you know
wanted to work for herself
and it seemed like you kind of have some
of that attitude you know well i like
the trucking thing
you do yeah and but i started it a
little later
than most because you wanted to have
children first yeah well
i had my kids first and that was the
most important thing and what did you
what were you doing during those
years staying home and trying to
maintain the bills and
taking care of them and it was it was
good it was financially tough as hell
yeah you know being pretty much single
but it
it got by we got by so yeah and then i
told them i was like when i get you know
stable
things will be better and it has been
money's
great it's a good job oh yeah yeah
1200 a week bring home after taxes
oh wow that's great it's nice money yeah
yeah
what you gonna do tonight you think
maybe your ladies at the house and it's
y'all relaxing y'all watching a movie uh
um
jaws or something and suddenly she wants
a couple crab legs or something like
that she's hungry for something she saw
in the film you know
she hungry for a little bit of carp or a
salmon
how you going to treat her right i'll
tell you how it grub hub
and especially now that grubhub has
grubhub
perks that's right grow pub first of all
has all the food you love from your
favorite
local restaurants it's nice to know that
every grubhub order
earns you points towards a future free
grubhub order that's right
with grubhub perks grubhub grub
what you love
oh sorry winter is coming i think a cold
ghost just passed right through my body
and just delved right out my nuts
and what i'm talking about is manscaped
what you don't know about manscape is
that if you don't have proper body hair
on your body
air can get trapped in you you might get
a
cold pocket of air trapped near your
crotch crap you're your nuts or thigh
you don't want that with manscape you
can trim accordingly
trim the hair on your body so the so
wind patterns
can pertinently migrate across your skin
manscaped has the new lawnmower 3.0
trimmer it's waterproof
with advanced skin safe technology oh
there's nothing worse
than santa nipping his own sack
you don't want it the weed whacker
is that ear nose hair trimmer
sometimes you see somebody step daddy
and they grow in a damn
you know their ear look like a damn uh
fern
cause of hair and you can defeat that
now
with manscaped you got smelly feet
manscape can help with their foot dust
or foot deodorant
made to fight otters fight otters from
the dirty feet
you want to smell good everywhere good
because manscaped also has a refined
cologne
it's time get it for a friend get it for
a love one get it for somebody you don't
even love
get it for some of the [ __ ] in your
family
anybody can enjoy manscaped you can get
20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com theo and you can support
the podcast
get some people in your fan and your
family manscape get them
you can't be having your man unscathed
sometimes you see an unscathed man out
there get his hair tangled up in a damn
power line
he'd get a hulk tangled up in his damn
hair
get 20 off in free shipping at
manscape.com
theo that's 20 off with free shipping at
t-h-e-o be be sure to join the manscaped
movement
we do a lot we try and we don't do a lot
but we try and do some stuff for
you know we all we admire hard-working
women and
i do work my ass off yeah so where do
you think that work ethic came from you
think
uh actually not having nothing
yeah yeah nothing gets handed to you if
it does there's a catch to it
oh there always is yeah yeah there's
always that catch
so for me to have something
gotta work and once they were old enough
and i didn't need babysitters and
you know diapers and bottles and they
could pretty much once they're in high
school take care of themselves oh once
they can make a pot of macaroni
yeah well he's a good cook my oldest boy
jeff he's a good cook
yeah yes he's he is so he you know he
helped out a lot too so
yeah we're good that's cool yeah um was
there another line of work that you
wanted to get into was always trucking i
know you mentioned that from
growing up you said from your dad was a
in in the business
uh was there another line of work that
you thought about not really um
i did try a concrete mixer yeah i drove
one of those
yeah and it didn't go very well it
started in november
and the old shoots that you used to
let the concrete roll down we're like uh
45 pounds a piece
you had to hook that yeah and you pick
up each one there's four
and what i'd have to do is like set it
down long ways
drop down to my knees let it drop on my
shoulder then kind of stand up from a
squat
and then walk it across and hook it and
do each one that way
and then i had to learn how to back up
the truck and work the chute at the same
time without overloading or spilling
concrete
damn the people that are working by the
hour
sweetest people ever take your time take
time we're good yeah
but the white collar that was actually
like
the suit thai people standing watching
you you spill a drop
and you're a piece of [ __ ] get the hell
out of here you don't know what you're
doing
and then that's just and so you just
pull up to job sites where it's been
ordered
yes the concrete and you say look i got
this load we're ready for
footers to a personal person's driveway
or sidewalk so now uh what was the first
one you said
what not not the sidewalk the other one
oh the driveways
uh purple's personal driveways or their
little garages or footers at buildings
like they're getting ready to start a
big mall or something and there's some
tubes that go in the ground and you got
to be filled with concrete yeah
so you could handle those so are there
some jobs you couldn't handle with
concrete where it's like they needed
like part of a wall done yeah
when somebody ordered some concrete um
i was actually there for this uh there
was another concrete truck that beat us
to the place and it was in a residential
area
he drives into their yard and sinks damn
yeah
so all the concrete it sunk up to the
tank so it the tank couldn't stir
and if it can't stir then the concrete
will set damn well it set
in the truck so all that got wasted
they'd have to jackhammer all that out
of there
really then they had to call tow truck
to get the truck pulled out of this
person's yard that they
damaged he's fired yeah yeah
yeah it seemed like a lot of extra risk
on that job then there's just so many
other variables where you could
you know lose your nut for the day you
know oh yeah yeah it's one mistake
i mean a heavy truck like that with
having it liquid in it there's that
surge
you know you make a turn and it'll surge
to the right oh because of that volume
of that converge to the left the weight
of that
of that you know to stop and it'll push
the truck forward
yeah crazy yeah damn almost makes me
damn erect that sounds freaking kind of
sexy was it a little no i actually like
the semis because
in november when you start out and
you're like spraying the truck down
and it's november you're getting wet i
don't care where the [ __ ] you stand
they'll say oh downwind i was like yeah
okay whatever
you got to get back in the truck you
peel all your clothes off you put them
on top of the heaters
and you got to let them warm and dry out
before you get to the next
stop and this is in a rig huh that's in
the semi
or the uh yeah okay and so you'll just
drive in your underwear
you could but you know put a t-shirt on
or something yeah
yeah you have to you have to because
i've sitting drove in my pajamas
and the old school truck drivers get
pissed off about that really oh yeah
you're supposed to be in blue jeans and
uh cowboy boots and a tucked in flannel
shirt
and now is that an actual protocol
you're supposed to be in for oh no
no it's just the older school the older
guys the old ones that's been driving 40
and 50 years yeah
you know that's the way that they did it
that's why you should do it you know
too many people out here wearing pajamas
yeah you know
somebody out here in damn pokemon
freaking onesie exactly
flip-flops and pajama bottoms and uh you
know or they'll come out with uh
eating caviar that ain't a real damn i
seen
this lady get out of a truck one time
and i don't know how in the hell she
drove like that
uh her fingernails were like three
inches long
damn she had on all this jewelry she had
this huge weave
she had on his fancy white outfit the
whole outfit was white
oh wow you gotta reach under the fifth
wheel you've gotta
touch greasy dirty [ __ ] and it's like
how the hell
is the high heels that look like they're
six inch spike boots how could you do
that you can't yeah
i wear tennis shoes like these maybe she
had a sidekick with her all right
she got out of the truck by herself you
know usually if you'll see somebody in a
passenger seat or
you'll see the truck move around for
somebody in the cab okay you know but
you didn't she just got out and i was
like ooh fancy pants
all righty then uh now are there some
fancy ladies out there on the circuit
what do you guys call it the circuit the
when you out you know just out the run
like when you're out on the
when you're on route otr or just yeah
what do you call it
it's it's just um hauling and you're in
route
you got destinations such as um you know
your pickups and deliveries and
you know you'll deliver here and then
you'll go somewhere else clink clear
across the country to pick up
you know that's dead heading that's
empty okay and then you'll go
pick up there and then you could deliver
somewhere else or
we bring it to the yard sometimes and
just drop it for the local guy to take
it and what's the yard prison you mean
no no it's uh the yard's like where our
company is
that's where our trailers are our trucks
are all at where the office is
the shop where they fix the trucks oh
that's cool we call it the yard yeah man
i bet my mom would
love doing that job she just likes
working for herself she likes
you know like i do too yeah not having a
ball standing over top maybe 24 hours a
day
yeah you know worrying about what you're
doing where you're at when you're coming
in
yeah yeah is there a level of proof in
your in your line of work that like i
want to prove to men that i can do this
or it has nothing to do with them
yeah yeah yes yes you and women have it
i think
in my opinion a little harder because we
have to prove that we can drive
right which is notoriously yeah been
misproven by women right
right especially in semi trucks i mean
we get picked on for driving especially
in south korea actually
are there any and i'll just ask point
blank because that's all i know is but
are there any asian truck drivers have
you seen any
man yeah men never seen asians
never see asian women driving never yeah
i think always the men always the men
yeah and they're tiny
oh yeah they're so tiny little jockey
little engine jobs just little tiny guys
oh yeah a little nine
pound fella yeah a little chin yam right
here
[Laughter]
well he weighs 19 pounds a little rice
little rice bit yeah
yeah just cruising yeah um it's a pretty
now i i i've i believe that the
the truck industry is getting pretty
diverse there's a lot of middle eastern
truck drivers now yes there is
yeah and to be honest with you everybody
that i have ever seen
or out there that's different you know
the towels and the beards you know
that's not a terrorist that's a truck
driver right
he's gotten out and actually helped me
before spot me and getting in the spot
you know just
just by there was no word communication
at all
he's just telling helping me out right i
didn't ask him he just
volunteered and done it yeah i'm driving
down the road i see him and they're like
this just a waving and it's like
what's up you know it's a pretty diverse
sport though these days yeah
yeah yeah because you would think
especially when i was growing up it
seemed like it was a white man kind of
did it yeah
um or black man white or black man you
see a lot of black men driving
um i see some black women driving yeah
um it's mostly white women driving
because you don't see a lot of
diverse women different different
countries women drama and it's usually
just
white yeah but or black um
i remember two men they had a lot of
hispanics a lot of hispanic drivers oh
yeah huh a whole lot
um and like i said a lot of foreign
a lot of foreigners they can't even
speak english like middle eastern guys
yeah
yeah yeah because i remember reading an
article a few years ago
um that about the
growing population of middle eastern men
that were driving long haul
yeah and it was like oh that's
interesting and i guess it was because
they also were buying a lot of the
service stations and stuff as well
so i think they're just you know one
business kind of led to the other maybe
oh yeah yeah it could have possibly um
let's take a question right here we got
a question from a beautiful young fella
right here
what's going on theo big fan been
listening for a while and i got a
question for the female trucker across
from you
so mit or somebody did some sort of
study on female truckers
and found that on a scale of one to ten
um
they ranked 4.4 on how safe they felt on
the road
so my question is what's the scariest
moment or interaction you've had as a
female trucker
um good question and how safe do you
feel on a scale of one to ten on the
road
um big fan theo gang gang hong kong
hang brother that's crazy two people did
hong kong
yeah what are the odds of hong kong yeah
yeah
uh that's a great question yeah what's
the safety like out there
um it it depends on where you're at
actually um
there's some places truck stops that
i've stopped at and i didn't know it at
the time
uh but i was told once i got back
obviously just didn't matter
uh that i could have got shot there damn
uh mugged for being a female does anyone
just anyone but also
female that's the bigger target right
you're weak
um defenseless you know oh yeah if i see
seven or eight people out
you know wandering around at night well
what i'm saying females
walking around you know sometimes
drivers actually think that you are a
lot lizard
oh yeah and you drive a truck oh yeah
yeah
and but now but but that would go
against the grain really to be a lot
lizard that also drives or do you think
they have that
they yeah i think they do i've actually
heard about that
yeah that there are women that will
charge to sleep
around in truck stops while they're
driving and they're making an extra
you know buck on the side yeah uh hell
no
i've seen some of the [ __ ] walking
around out there you wouldn't hook up
with it
hell no no now do they have uh so so you
said so some of the truck stops can be
kind of shady yes
um is there a like
do you feel like is there moments where
you feel like scared like
you go into a place it's nate it's it's
night time you're walking back to your
truck
do you guys usually park a distance away
from the
yes service station i try to keep
everything i need in the truck
so the only time i have to get out is
for fuel or if i have to do a pre-trip
and you check your truck before you go
now there's been times that i've gotten
out and literally
been so scared that i'd run back before
my pre-trip was finished
just that creepy ominous gut feeling
that somebody's watching you
yeah now take me through one more time
the pre-trip what is it it's uh when you
get out and your trucks run and you
check your oils you check all your
fluids you
make sure your turning signals work you
know the pressure in your tires
make sure everything's just smooth and
you walk it
you make sure your air lines are all
hooked up you walk your truck you check
everything yes
everything make sure doors are still
locked and loaded you know fastened and
then
come back around and once it's all done
usually it takes about 20 minutes
oh wow yeah so you want to check
everything now do you use a pressure
gauge when you're checking the tires
no usually i'll just dump them i'll take
a hammer and hit them
now you can tell like the way it bounces
off that they're pretty full
but if you hear a thud and it doesn't
bounce
usually that means it's flat or it's
going flat okay so it's kind of like
what you look for
and how many wheels do you actually have
on it 18. damn
18. i knew it oh yeah two stairs
so you got two four six eight drives
and then the rest are all trailer so
what do you mean so you got eight drives
eight
so it's an eight wheel yeah so it's
eight wheel drive yeah
let's say yes when it sits yeah see one
two
three four one two
three four i'm trying to think yeah no
it's tricky
now it's if he could pull up a picture
of the trucks
and he can actually count because it is
18 total
but i'm trying to like i got a brain
fart going on here
yeah there you go there was a perfect
picture right there
okay there's the bottom of this one up
there at the top
next to the red one there you go that's
it
so those are your 34 yeah you got you
got the eight
eight drives two drives yes and the 10
or just
trailer yeah wow so now if you take the
trailer off then you're an eight-wheeler
no it's 10 10 on the cab honey oh it is
yeah yeah
10 total you got two in the front and
then eight
in the back so it's ten on the ten on
the cab okay so
we got eight on the trailer yeah that's
where i was trying to think something
don't sound right
wait a minute hang on hang on let me
think yeah i was thinking you had four
in the front i'm
yeah i really went wrong there yeah yeah
two up front
and then eight on the back of the of the
what is the whole it's called a bob tail
a bob tail bob tail
that's the that's your whole cab with no
trailer okay it's bob tail so that's the
bob tail yeah oh that's cool
yeah okay so you get to a uh a services
you do your pre
pre-trip mm-hmm so take off before you
take off to what leave or to go into the
service station or whatever
no it's before you leave like if you're
fixing to take off anywhere okay
like you just got a new load you're
getting ready take off with you picked
up or
say you're waking up in the morning
after your 10-hour break that's when you
really want to check it because there's
people that will unhook your airlines
while you're sleeping damn
or they'll pull your fifth-wheel pin why
and it's just to be a jerk
and if they pull that pin and you take
off and you ain't checked it
your whole trailer will drop right off
and your cables will still be hooked and
ripped oh yeah they'll rip right out
that happened to me at the gas station
all the time i'll put that gas in fill
that bastard up
take off baby cost you 170 dollars i'll
tell you that praise god i've spent
almost i've spent almost 800
ripping them [ __ ] off and you don't
get to keep the thing you got to give
the thing back yeah
yeah they always want that little uh
pump thingy back
and the whole bastard yeah they went
with it yeah just hateful man it's big
business you know
we've seen trucks that like them so much
they took them with them too oh yeah i
can imagine
we want a souvenir from the truck stop
yet how long does it take to fill up a
truck when you go to
fill up gas and are y'all on diesel what
are y'all running
diesel fuel okay diesel fuel only and
then you've got the def
which is a diesel efficient fuel and it
smells like cow piss
is it two different types of fuel yeah
okay so tell me so tell me about that so
you can't so can you pull into just like
a exxon and get some gas or no
no because our company uses the points
for pilots and flying js
okay so you pull into those specific
stations yeah well now if it's emergency
fuel we can use a ta or petrol or a
loves
but he prefers us using those right so
he gets extra bonus on the points
right so we go there and use those and
it usually takes about
oh yeah about 10 minutes to fuel it up
completely
and i think it's uh 250 gallons
yeah yeah so dude if you get in an
accident you're going to die oh
yeah you're going swimming in some
diesel fuel wow yeah
that's wild yeah um when you were
do a lot of uh are there a lot of
swingers out there on the road because
i would imagine couples go ride together
sometimes do you see that
yeah there's husband and wife teams a
lot and i like i had when i started i
had male trainers
okay for me it was easier just to listen
to a guy
you know i don't think two girls cooped
up in a truck is a good idea
oh well these two women died that did it
in that movie
thelma louise them [ __ ] died man so
you're probably right about that you
know uh
but yeah i think um you know i won't
even have the
if if there's someone who's driving me
an uber or anything like that
and they have the female voice on the
phone
i'll have them turn it off or change it
it reminds me of my mother's voice i
think or just reminds me of something
like this tom
i was going to fire his ass several
times for getting me in the places i
ain't supposed to be with a semi-truck
yeah
tom you're an [ __ ] um do you keep the
voice on the whole time do you shut it
down
no i have to shut him off he gets on my
nerves i wanted to sling him out the
window before
yeah you know um speed warning speed
warning
speed warning so hell no shut up yeah
how fast can you go in the in the rig 72
that's
top speed there's a limit on it yes it's
governed as fast as it'll go
now if you're going downhill that's a
different story you can get it in
neutral and let it open up
uh you can just leave it in in the gear
it's in 10th gear but
if you're heavy and you can't control it
stopping doing that
really but i'll let it cruise about 75.
hey man
rock and roll yeah let's live a little
bit gotta get there put on some acdc and
cut it up
yeah hold the steering wheel great yeah
yeah what do you listen to while you're
in there oh all different kinds of [ __ ]
there's uh
some clandonia music that i listen to
it's irish
yeah and it's bagpipes and drums oh wow
and that'll get you [ __ ] pumped because
you you're driving and it just
you know it'll get you hyped up where
you're really seriously going it's like
uh
clandonium it's called yeah clandonia
clandonia yeah
huh yeah and it's straight up irish
and it's it's like the titanic music
that i listen to when they're in the
lower deck oh yeah and they're partying
it's kind of like that but it's
basically just drums and bagpipes
now you're like damn william wallace out
there there yeah yeah
uh and the truck is my sword yeah
do you do you keep a weapon on you and
yeah i got some oc spray for my son okay
yeah and a hammer works really well
okay uh guns no uh we could have one
but it i don't i don't really want it
personally in
the company truck yeah you know our boss
is pretty lenient about it but he's not
like giving us the okay
it's like you can protect yourself but i
don't really want to know about it
okay you know and he's a good guy so
here's a fella right here that also owns
an animal and they got a question
hey yo what up theo what up guests my
question is
is there equivalent male lot lizards for
female truckers
anyway gang gang bruh gang baby that's a
great question
yeah how much sensuality is out there on
the uh
a lot really yes um there's a
couple of places uh in indiana that's
way up north way up north that's there's
a truck stop that's really
bad about it and they will just pound
the [ __ ] out of your door
and they're men women women mostly women
and they're showing up for sex
yeah no i mean i ain't sticking my head
out that curtain yeah
because if it happens to be a man
i really don't want them knowing that
there's a woman in the truck right
so i just keep to myself back there will
you do a man's voice or something
like that [ __ ] off yeah you know
it's pretty good pretty good
[ __ ] off you know and it'll work it'll
work you know
you keep the lights off yeah you know
and you don't let them know that you're
you know prancing around in there you
just don't make yourself known
you just try to keep to yourself keep
doors locked so you feel pretty safe
once you're locked up and everything's
locked down for the night
you feel pretty safe yeah the rides had
me scared though
yeah because i was worried about you
know the busting of the windshield the
busting of the side windows
because then they can climb right in
yeah and the the sad thing is every time
you see one of those riot videos they're
always stopping a rig you know yeah
yeah i've seen them pull the drivers out
of there oh yeah and that's scary
and the bosses told us what to do you
know if that ever happened
he's like you pull up you blow your horn
you let him know to get off
he's like don't ever roll your windows
down keep your doors locked
and he said turn on your flashers he
said you call the police on your headset
but you continuously keep moving do not
stop
and if somebody so stupid does stand in
front of your truck and get squashed and
that's what's gonna happen
you know if you stop then you're setting
yourself up to get hurt
yeah be even if they're just protesting
there are some of them that are out to
just
yeah some of them aren't out there
protest they don't want uh
you know black lives matter or any life
matter yeah
this is totally i want your [ __ ] in that
truck yeah they want your life not to
matter
yeah give me your money i want your
radio i can get this i can get that
and as your truck is just slowly rolling
away and they're getting the crap beat
out of you yeah
you know it's also getting stripped on
the inside and then
you know by the time you get back to it
you know half bleeding and dead you're
like what the hell
you can't even drive back somebody get
me
you know so that's that's it spooked me
but that's a good plan though
flash flashers going contact the police
on the headset and just keep it cruising
yeah
yep it's a low speed you don't try to
fly through like they're bowling pins
you know
which you'd like to just cartoon you
know watch them just fly left and right
as you plow through
oh man i definitely take on some antifa
son yeah you know
they run four four they run four or
eight rigs through that park up there in
portland and i think that
did you ever see the video on uh the
internet where the fedex driver was
or was ups i can't remember which but
was when it first started the riots
this guy was climbing all over this
truck and he was
it was threatening you bring that up
sean and uh
the fedex truck took off and the guy
actually got pinned in the wheels as the
trucks rolling people are screaming for
him to stop
why would why would he stop they were
climbing all over him there was like
20 people all over these days how
suddenly you defend yourself
jungle gym you know it was just on
youtube brother it was really scary
and i cried for the person that got
rolled over i did i felt bad it was a
horrible video
but at the same time i'd have done the
same thing as that fedex driver
had to you don't know what they would
have done to him
you know to get his whatever he's
carrying
yeah i'm not dying uh st louis man dies
are being dragged by fedex
that's it yeah here we go
they may have cut it because it was
pretty violent
i don't know if they clipped it or not
but yeah man you're doing your job
somebody interferes because they have
some
social right uh social justice issue
what is fedex this is just thieves this
is just people stealing that these
people aren't about any this isn't about
anything
right i think this is pretty much it but
this was this was pretty sad
the guy got him see how he's got the
double trailers
he got him between the two he got in
between the two of them and got wedged
in there
and he got drunk quite a ways before you
know the video
what your mindset is because i've been
in mindsets where i feel like i need to
stand up for myself or i feel like i
need
some sort i want to act out for some
sort of justice
but then also going in between two semi
trucks
just doesn't seem
like where i'm going to find any of that
right thank you for enjoying this
episode with this beautiful trucker
and i want to tell you something right
now that the holidays are upon us and
it's a good time to take care of
yourself and others
and you want to communicate with people
during the holidays you don't have to be
yelling down the street
you don't have to be writing a message
in a bottle and throwing it in a sewer
throwing it out in uh
the ravine or something what i'm telling
you about is mint
mobile mint mobile's best offer of the
year
is here for a limited time buy any
three-month plan
and get three more months for free
that's six months for the cost of three
by going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail
mint mobile is passing those significant
savings on
to you all mint mobile plans can come
with unlimited talk and text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan
and keep your same phone number along
with all your existing contacts
and if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied and that's full satisfaction
as much as you can get mint mobile has
you covered
with their seven day money back
guarantee
you have nothing to lose you can keep
your current phone
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service
starting at just fifteen dollars a month
why haven't you heard about this because
you're just finding out about it why
hasn't everybody done this because
they are just finding out about it for a
limited time only
our listeners buy any three month mint
mobile plan and get three more months
free
by going to mint mobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mint mobile.com
theo cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month
at mintmobile.com theo
and i got to tell you right now my you
know i'm do i'm looking for a home right
now
and if you've seen on my instagram story
story you see me looking through
something
you know i look at i'll go look at
anything a lean too
a two-story one-story half-story hell
i took a tour of a burning building the
other day and almost leased it
but i have credit issues i can't get a i
have a
previous mortgage that i didn't make
some payments on i missed two payments
and it did they call it dings on your
credit my credit's all dinged
up you know like a little uh
like a chinese automobile you know my
thing's all jacked up
thankfully bridge credit solutions is
helping me
bridge credit solutions they are backed
with a hundred percent money back
guarantee
for any items that cannot be removed
from your credit
you will not find that anywhere
you'll know exactly what you're paying
for at the beginning of the repair
i reached out to bridge i know what
they're repairing on my credit
if they can't do it then i get my money
back
there's no open-ended monthly fees it's
written in the contract what work is to
be done
and how much you're paying you will need
to have the bridge credit report access
prior to scheduling your audit they
cannot go over your credit
report without this thankfully it cost
just one dollar
and can be found on the website by
simply clicking on the services drop
down bar
where you'll see bridge report access
bridge credit solutions is helping me
so i can refinance so i can get the
mortgage
bridge credit solutions prides itself on
its lightning quick turnaround
that's right you can feel free to call
or text no matter the hour
with whatever questions or concerns you
may have
simply go to bridgecreditsolutions.com
theo that's right go to
bridgecreditsolutions.com
theo and start repairing your credit
today
the money you're going to save in the
long term on those mortgage payments
you want to get the credit fixed now and
now back to the episode
do you um have you met any men out there
no will you be on apps dating man
meeting men in different cities like do
you have a couple of
you know a couple of songbirds out there
that you let on the branch every now and
then no
no i got somebody at home and
you you get approached by all different
kinds of men out there
for different they'll use all different
reasons to try to get your phone number
now what is some of that take me through
a little bit um one of them is uh
i uh i like the trucks y'all are driving
uh
tell me about your company are they
hiring can i have their phone number
it's like sure so i'll write down
karen's number you know give it to him
and
tell him to talk to nick you know he'll
he gets you a job we're always hiring
and they don't call they're not calling
oh well can i have your number to let
you know how it's going i said hell no
what the [ __ ] you want my number for
he's like and that's exactly what he
said that's what i would have said
damn he jumped back just like he's like
whoa whoa whoa whoa
and i was like but what you need my
number for and he's like well i was just
gonna let you know how
you know the process is going i said
they'll do that thank you very much
you're a shark on them now do you hear
any stories about those places that's
popular for swingers and stuff because i
would imagine here's what i'm saying is
if you're taking a
spouse out there if you're a man and you
have a female
side p sidekick with your wife you know
or whatever it is called
and i can't imagine y'all aren't doing
swinging and there's a lot of swinging
out there in the midwest too especially
in missouri
oh do you encounter any of that hey do
you hear any stories of it is there any
no actually if there's it mostly what i
see is men that are single out there
picking up
the lot lizards okay you know and
they'll get what they want and then send
them on their way and then they stop to
the next truck you know
is it usually set or they is it [ __ ]
and is it oral sex do you know what it
is
i don't even know yeah it just i guess
it would depend on the girl and how much
money he wants to spend you know but
yeah
do you know the rates on any of it how
how no
i wouldn't want to yeah because it's
literally like
you got to worry about them girls
sometimes because i've been told
that they can actually lay underneath
your trailer
and as you're coming out to say if
you're a man you're standing out there
taking a piss
they cut your ankle they can cut you cut
you in the back of it
rob rob your ass just like hostile and
that's you got to watch them i've
watched them at night when i just
pulled in and it's two o'clock in the
morning and it's been raining
i'll see you know it's it's actually
raining there's a woman walking around a
pair of shorts and high heels
and she's tapping well it's dark
can't really tell that helps but you see
her you know going from door to door to
door to truck to truck to truck
and then the next thing you know she
disappears for about 20 minutes
and then she's out again you'll see a
light on in the truck that's the dome
then you know they tell us
i know what you're doing uh-huh and then
she'll come out but
i've seen them walk around the trucks
like they're looking for [ __ ]
right or maybe they're gonna disconnect
something or pull something
you got to watch them because you don't
know what they're doing well they have
that famous documentary with eileen
warnos where she
wasn't she killing truckers no she
actually was killing just
random people that was picking her up
right she was prostituting herself out
and just randomly picked out some dudes
and
do you see is there any pimping or
anything like going on out there do you
see anything like that do you know who's
approached my trucks
and my truck is usually men drivers
other men drivers
just wanting us now are they asking
specifically for sex they're just kind
of flirting or
saying i had a bosnian guy he told me he
was from bosnia
and uh he wanted to tell me how big and
beautiful my boobs were
oh and i was like okay okay you know
pretty cool
i mean first of all that is nice it was
in maryland you know i'll tell you this
if a lady came up to my window for no
reason and said hey man i like this
yeah yeah well this is kind of scary you
know you're a girl in the truck by
yourself you're right
my bad you're right anyways he's uh
he sticks his body halfway in my window
okay it's a beautiful day i had to wind
us down which is stupid
you don't do that so he put his head in
the window and he was in his body was
okay
the window up to halfway yeah i'm
standing there making up my bed you know
just kind of going to stretch out or
watch tv yeah the window's open it's
nice outside
beautiful day next thing i know i turned
around and i was like ah i screamed and
i was like
you could get a shot like that dude what
the [ __ ] get out of my truck
damn and he's like or not he wasn't bad
looking
now we're talking but it's a steal bossy
let me see where it is on a map
yeah check it out bring him in because i
asked him if he was rushing and he got
pissed at me
oh yeah they get upset he's like oh hell
no i'm not rushing we'll just wear a
sign that says bosnian then dude
cause it's like where are you from and
he's like bosnia
yeah we hate russians yeah they'll fight
man they love to fight russia
yeah um maybe google bosnia bosnian man
outdoors maybe but yeah he told me that
uh if uh
if he he would hate himself if he didn't
tell me that he wanted to
have a good time i was like roll on
alabama i
know no the bearded guy look at him
let's look at that guy down a little
third row no i'll tell you what he
looked like was more like the
uh the top roll up there and third guy
that's the same guy but i mean
that's more like the picture okay that's
what he looked like wow
handsome kind of like he said a little
bit handsome he was okay oh yeah but it
was just too weird man
yeah it's a bit of a heavy approach you
know you can't do the flake thing you
know it's kind of flaky
yeah yeah you can't just peek in my
window no yeah it wasn't a pivot
um it wasn't a peak it was not a peak it
was a full blown
wow i'm hip on your truck you got big
beautiful boobs yeah
and i was like oh my god it's like i
would hate myself if you not have sex
with me
in my truck did he say that yeah
basically yeah he wanted me to get out
and have sex with him in his truck
i was like get the hell out of here at
least he really laid it out you know
i guess exactly yeah because that's a
tough thing on this podcast we try to
encourage young men to like at least
shoot their shot you know but that's
kind of a shady way to do it well i'll
tell you some funny stuff too about
other
episodes as well we had a i was doing a
dedicated run which is the same thing
every day and i was leaving from our
shop which is in louisville
to indianapolis ups okay
and coming back same thing every night
well started running into the same fella
that
in a car right up alongside of me just
grinning and a waving
you know from his car and i'm like hey
how you doing
and i'm driving on you know next thing i
know he's blown his horn
so i glanced down and he's got his junk
hanging out oh wow
okay his penis huh yeah oh yeah wow then
he backs off
okay then he comes back up alongside of
me again he's grinning even bigger this
time
oh yeah his pants are down to his knees
this time okay
well i'm sitting here just driving you
know like literally wanting to put my
hand next to my face you know and just
kids here
because i'll slow down you know for them
to speed up a little bit then they'll go
back and then they'll
keep alongside of me the whole time no
matter what i'm doing oh yeah regardless
of the traffic that's going on around us
it's just you and them in the world
it's like i saw this guy five
separate occasions same stretch of 65
in india indiana and i named him jerk
off jim
oh yeah he's out there huh
he painted his steering wheel oh yes he
did
what color the white ooh
[Music]
that body glaze i bet damn nasty
so you can now you could see his penis
now can you see from the tr
from your oh yeah it's the perfect view
you can see over to the driver's side
i can see everything wow inside of a
vehicle
a four-wheeler so if i'm driving right
and i have my penis
out yes can you and you're in a uh
in a rig yes how can you see my wiener
can you see it from
through the front window no it's from
the side your side window the passenger
side so you can see from the passenger
from over
me wow so you're passing me in the fast
lane i'm in the slow lanes two lane
highway
like i-65 is through indiana yeah i
could see everything inside of your
vehicle your back seat
front seat drive so if i put my penis
out you could see it i could see
everything that's all i could almost
count the hairs oh wow
almost hell yeah i didn't know y'all had
such a good size
oh it's a hell of a view it's the
upstairs view from you know
seeing y'all from downstairs what about
this did um
do you see a lot of like uh oral sex
going on between couples occasionally
i'm sure you see a little bit of that
sometimes
it yes and no yeah but most of the time
they're not
like you know trying to show it right
they're just right on down the road i
was like oh damn did you see that
there ain't nobody in the truck with me
i'm just like yeah
have you ever had a guest in the truck a
male guest or no oh just
i've had my oldest son with me once and
i had
my daughter with me she got to grind
with me once and
uh i did have a team
a member from work co-worker we did team
for nine months
running back and forth to miami florida
twice a week and is that was that
enjoyable or no hell no
i hated it really yes because y'all
started getting on each other's nerves
oh oh my god
i wanted to kill him oh there's so many
times that i almost left him at truck
stops oh yeah and that's for you chris
if you ever listen to this amen chris
yeah chris chris santana yeah smacking
your [ __ ] gums while you're eating
yeah damn bruh tell everybody's toenails
in the floor
oh body hair in the bed sheets come on
the crisp bottle's rolling around uh-uh
he pee in a bottle
[ __ ] yeah god water bottle really
rolling around there's there's two water
bottles oh it breaks my heart oh
it broke mine oh i wonder women y'all
so you guys ever pee in like a pan or
something in a cup
in a cup yeah but as you're driving down
interstate like if you're teaming
yeah and they're driving and you got to
pee that window goes down
and out goes the piss and you keep the
cup amen and what do you do with the cup
just sign it and give it to me now you
stuff a paper towel down in it put the
little top back on you know where the
straw goes
and that way it keeps the smell down you
put it in a bag i like that
yeah sanitary reasons little tricks of
the trade you learn as you go huh yeah
yeah um we had a question that came in
right here from some gentleman or or
yeah this fella right here this happy
guy right here
hey theo my name is brooks long time
listener from florida south carolina my
question for your guest tonight is we
all know that truck stops for the mecca
of the dark arts
what's the craziest thing you've ever
seen go down at a truck stop
thank you for everything you guys both
do love you gang gang
gang brother i'll tell you almost i'll
lead on this one go ahead
so i was going to college
and and i did go and
i went from louisiana and i drove
to uh tucson arizona
and i had worked all summer man to save
up some money so i had me about 1200
in cash and i'd stayed up i was up i was
doing uppers gas station uppers no doses
oh yeah you know snorting whatever
caffeine pill you can get your hands on
oh
i was snorting it yeah dude i did half a
damn mountain dew code
i did half of mountain dew code red
straight through one of my nostrils
[Applause]
yeah oh i don't care i do it at all you
know
so anyway so i'm up man i've been up for
probably about 20 hours
in my car i had this uh 84
some kind of car i don't know what it
was didn't even matter really it was a
piece of [ __ ] but
um it would overheat so about every
maybe 150 miles it got too hot and so i
had to pull over and wait about 40
minutes for it to go down and then i had
to
make wait for it to cool off so i could
put the water in the uh radiator
radiator and then go but start back
again
well i've been up for [ __ ] a day and
a half and i wasn't doing real well so i
stopped at a truck stop
and uh i guess it was maybe nevada i'm
not sure about or arizona or
west texas somewhere but man i had all
my money and i was like i can't leave it
in my car somebody could break in i'll
leave it on my person right so i
took it put it in my underpants my cash
right so i went into this gas station i
found a place somewhere upstairs they
had like this little lobby kind of place
and i just laid on a bench up there and
just went to sleep
well i slept for about 40 minutes and i
forgot that i had my cash from
underpants when i stood up it just fell
out my pant leg and i lost all my money
no you didn't lost it all man holy [ __ ]
then here's the shady part then you're
wandering around a gas station for two
and a half hours asking people if they
found 1200
cash right like they're gonna tell you
hey yeah or not
i'll tell you oh sure is it yours would
you like to have it back
none of them are going to tell you no
and the worst part is they all think
you're on drugs and [ __ ]
oh yeah like you're looking for a piece
of crack you dropped on the ground
like have you found 1200 cash in here
and they're like this dude is on [ __ ]
yeah you want dope man yeah do you run
in what do you run into out there have
you seen anything wild is there anything
going on out there
i've seen fist fights over parking or
fuel spots really yeah or they're in
such a hurry
they get into an actual fist fight over
getting feel who gets it first damn i've
actually gotten a screaming match with
somebody once
over that and how does that work because
you're coming in at a certain angle
they're
looping around what it is is that you
gotta get you take your turns
you know just like you would need a you
know gas station
and the the semi truck in front of you
that's supposed to be getting fuel
there's nobody fueling
it's just sitting there idling so i run
in to go pay for a parking spot because
all the free ones are taken so you get a
reserve spot
that's about 18 15 to 18 okay so it's
almost like a koat campground like you
right
you don't have to park to pay in park
but there are some that are free
yes interesting the ones that are free
are the shittier spots in the back
right it's twisted and turned it's hard
to get to out on the [ __ ] rape trail
right right and down there in the back
lower 40s nose bleeds where there's no
light
you know do you is there a lot of drug
use out there you see any of it
what are these guys on out there i know
some of them are probably doing pills
yeah that's i've smelt it they come in
the truck stops and they walk past you
and they smell like a brewery
but there are truck stops that sell beer
you wouldn't think that a pilot flying
jay loves or anything like that would
actually sell liquor
but there are some that that sell
alcohol
and they could sit in there and get
sauced all they want in their truck and
as long as they're sober i guess by in
the morning
they driving and what are you what are
you doing for uh
for for food in there do you take food
of your own do you stop
and get stuff what are you yeah when i'm
off on saturday or sunday
monday maybe sunday and monday uh i'll
go to walmart get
everything i need and put it in you know
stock up my truck paper towels food
drinks water everything and load it all
up in there and then
go on down the road so if i get hungry i
can actually take everything out
make a sandwich or i can stick things in
the microwave
cook it yeah and if you're taking off
you're starting off on a on a haul right
yeah
what's the snacks you get out the gate
what's that gateway snack
uh set up you like to pro donuts really
you start with a couple donuts huh
powder donuts oh they're good yeah can't
drink milk no more because of getting
old and uh can't
can't handle it so i get the lactose
free and it's like the cartons
and i'll just have a little knob and
turn up the milk and you know
doughnut or two they say you know you've
got this powder ring all over your face
and you're wiping it off and it's all
over your shirt oh yeah yeah
you're like oh this lady parties yeah
yeah this ladies
you know [ __ ] flying yeah it's pretty
cool but there was a question the guy
that's what the most dangerous thing was
yeah i did get trash there was a time
when i was doing a pre-trip and it was
in early in the morning sun was out it
was bright
beautiful morning and i was actually
close to the truck stop too
i went out way out in the parking lot
and
it sounds like a bad joke but it's
really not i had my hood open
checking all my fluids checking my belts
everything that needed to be checked
plus i was still green at it so it's
taken me a while to make sure i'm
actually
probably over checking right you're
doing it all right and here comes
this hispanic guy he wants to know about
how to unplug
the elogs in your truck and i was
telling him oh you go inside of the
storage door of your truck and open it
sometimes you can unplug it
well can you come over here to the truck
and show me i was like no
no i just told you you can go check it
yourself damn so i went all about my
business
wiping stuff you know checking here
comes two white dudes
where's his husband at i was like
i said yeah straight straight straight
to it i said he's in there taking a [ __ ]
which i was in there by myself i don't
tell nobody that fake [ __ ] husband trip
yeah and he's like uh
really okay they just stood there and
he's talking amongst themselves
i started getting nervous and after
about 10 minutes you know me ignoring
them
a guy said uh that must be one long [ __ ]
i said he's probably just getting
something to eat since he's [ __ ]
yeah and he finally they walked out of
life right there this black guy
a milli vanilli reject oh damn but he's
a big dude
big dude big tall 6'3 muscles
he came in and he's got the long braids
he's got one braid hanging in the front
he's like
come over here and give a brother some
love and i was like uh
no i said i got a run to do i drive a
truck
you know and i put the hood down latched
them and started walking over to the
driver's side you know kind of a quick
speed
and get in my seat and go to grab the
door
to shut it and he grabs hold of my wrist
no way
and he yanks he yanks so hard that i use
my feet my other hand to hold myself in
the truck
and he's like come and give me some love
and he when he yanked
and i braced and caught myself i grabbed
a yank my
wrist back and shut the door and i was
already trying to put it in gear before
i'd even release the brakes
like i'm really trying to take off and
the truck's like
because the brakes are still on so i had
to release them
took off and trying to peel out of there
on gravel in fourth gear you know it's a
heavy truck and it's like
and i get down the road and get on the
interstate and broke down and just like
damn near cried damn you know because i
just went limp
this guy just tried to yank me out of
the truck
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me so i
texted on the e logs of my company
werner
at the time the guy just tried to pull
me out
and sent it and they're like be careful
that's it that's it honey yeah that's
the world baby that's the world be
careful
yeah all right so thanks for the advice
i knew that
appreciate it thank you very much yeah a
lot of guys with those dreadlocks
they'll use them to tie you down
oh [ __ ] i need to look like you beat you
with them oh yeah
i saw a black guy at the gym he had two
dreadlocks and he was doing them like
those wrote like you know like those
things were long enough they could be
used as lassos oh people doing
you know people doing around the throat
yeah it's risque out there
yeah it is it's scary it's french risk
baby what else uh
anything else come in over there uh sean
what's up theo baby this is your boy
jacob
coming straight at you from hillsboro
oregon what's up jake i have just one
question
for your guest yes and that is how the
hell
do you stay awake for some of your
long-haul drives
because anytime i have to drive for six
plus hours
especially at night boy
you know i'm gonna start nodding off and
having to pull over at those sketchy ass
rest stops
so just uh if you could let me know one
of your secrets
bless up i'd appreciate it gang gang
amen
yeah what's the tricks there because i
you know what is the tricks
coffee opening up the window as far down
as it'll go
no matter how cold it is really yeah air
conditioning in the face
uh i've actually slapped myself a couple
of times oh yeah i've done that
and i've took my fingertips and i'll sit
there and tap
the closed eyes to try to wake up
i've used cold washcloths on the eyes
visine helps coffee coffee coffee
um and getting out and walking
stretching yes yeah because you got to
get your legs out in a straight position
and your ass falls numb yeah so you
gotta get the blood flowing
does your ass fall asleep after a while
oh hell yeah wow yeah
you don't feel your butt crack it's
completely gone
it feels like one big giant pillow it's
like wow
who needs shocks
yeah i never i can't even imagine it's
having that ghost ass feel you know yeah
oh yeah well it's uh ais is what it's
called it is
yeah ass and seat really yeah that's
when you don't stop
and you run the whole you run the whole
thing damn except for your 30-minute
break
i've done that before a few times what
is uh
now are there some outfits in some
groups where they can just drive and
they don't have to follow those rules do
some people
break the rules some people i think the
only ones that can do that i
i don't know not positive it's like farm
equipment
they don't have to have certain rules i
think they're allowed on and off the
road but they can't like travel long
distances
but they don't have to have restrictions
and endorsements and
they can just get on with their tractor
but get get off you know
but no requirements what uh what's a
snack that you'll kind of wait to have
oh if you've been out there
a while what's a snack maybe you what's
a snack that you want you won't have
while you drive is there something
you've had from the gas station like oh
this makes me sick i'm not having this
again hot dogs
really yeah that's an instant enema you
want to eat a hot dog take [ __ ]
there you go it's a risky movie oh yeah
you don't want to
in their chili oh any any place that
serves their own
cooked chili may smell good may look
good it's really cold outside
taking bum yum yum you know warm chili
dude that's like a lava just pouring out
of a volcano
[Laughter]
oh ass on fire
we've all done some things um yeah
so they're so so uh is there anything
that makes who couldn't drive truck
is there what's what are there types of
people that couldn't drive truck what
does it take to be a driver
you gotta want to drive okay yeah that's
the first thing if you don't like
driving
any kind of driving that's in your own
car or anything then you ain't got no
business in it
uh you have to have some patience
because people are idiots out there
yeah i mean there's there's there's too
many of them and you got all the road
rage
and you got to control your own road
rage um
but just anybody could drive if you
wanted to
you know if you wanted to bad enough and
you just keep trying
you can do it it takes a lot of studying
a lot of practice
really yeah backhand's hard backing up
to me yeah
some people are born with the you know
that just being able to do it
yeah yeah like just gravy yeah get your
eyes closed and get it right in there go
back up benny yeah
uh those there i give the finger that's
what i say man yeah
[ __ ] effort i had to try i had to
practice
oh yeah yeah but i'm better at it i
ain't gonna stay in perfect dad and
never will be
they'll have days where i could back in
a spot that's
you know super tight and then there's
other days that i can't back into a
football field yeah you know and i've
heard that from other drivers too
same thing just kind of just happened
happy days yep yep
um what's the number one thing you got
to remember while you're out there
driving i mean uh
is it safety is it patience i mean you
said patience but
um just trying to think if there's
anything else that we're kind of missing
out any world that we're missing out on
you have to have like six sets of
eyeballs
running all the time and people don't
understand
what it's what the truck consists about
that's a lot is the ignorance of the
other people they don't know how heavy
it is
they don't know that we're getting over
to
avoid hitting somebody on the shoulder
that's broke down
they think we're just cutting them off
you know so get the hell out of my way
nobody likes being behind them
right we're a little slower for a reason
you know sometimes it is because of the
weight but then there's other times that
we have to keep our distance
further back than they do you know they
ride bumper to bumper in cars you know
and we have to stay back
that's which is uh 12 seconds at least
that's the rule yeah is there what about
the headlights you all use those to
sim to like notate things to each other
yeah it's it's a code um flipping
headlights can and especially during the
day can mean usually there's a
police officer d.o.t sitting somewhere
um
it could mean a wreck up the road they
you know flipping them seriously
you know you come over the hill there
might be an accident down there
or um or somebody pulled over
a lot of cops pulled over somebody on
the side of the road
and it could mean high beams basically
turn your lights down
well i've got them led lights they're
super strong
and they you know they're like x-ray
vision yeah yeah and i get headlighted
you know high beamed all the time and
there's nothing i have to show them that
i got
no they want some high beam there you go
you know
they are on low dammit what do you want
me to do what
ain't nothing do about it is it fun
being out there by yourself sometimes
yes cruising
yes i like looking around i love the
woods
and it's it's peaceful you know there's
times that i miss my family i miss my
kids
my grandbabies my cat you know
and but then there's times that it's
like i can't wait after the weekend of
being home i'm ready to go back out
yeah i like driving the trucks i like
shifting gears
i feel like king kong on the road
sometimes yeah yeah
i guess it does give you a feeling of
power out there yes it does yes it does
and you got control too because you you
can
if you have to hold your own lane and
you have to stay where you're at because
you cannot change lanes to help somebody
that's
getting off the ramp every now and then
it's gratifying when somebody actually
has to stop and let me go
you know i don't have to stop for you
i'm just going to keep on rolling [ __ ]
you
hey i actually had a cop
try to pass me on a ramp which was
ridiculous
it's like the worst thing ever and it
was police officer
and i'm in the slow lane traffic's
pretty heavy
there's a lot of traffic coming off the
ramp getting on to the interstate
so i move over into the middle lane i'm
keeping up with traffic and they're
moving off pretty slow because they're
just getting on so
i kindly start to pass them there's
still just a tiny bit of ramp left
because i let them all go on about their
business i get back over into slow lane
and i just out of the corner of my eye
just happen to glance over my side
mirror
there's a freaking cop that's running
alongside of me and he's running out of
road
and it's like him getting squashed
between me and a guardrail
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
and he ends up backing off because i
held my own i was like piss on you
yeah i'm where i'm supposed to be i
don't know what the hell you're doing
but he ended up backing off got behind
me and then ended up into the hammer
lane let's keep scooting on off yeah and
then rolled on down the road and i said
yeah that's what i thought
amen
do you feel like i bet there's a lot are
there some murderers that you feel like
ever
met a murderer out there because i bet
there's a lot of murderers and you
probably have
trucking and not know it because i've
heard about that there was a
truck driver that heard about that was
picking up hitchhikers and stuff like
lizards or whatever
and chaining them inside of the cab of
his truck
yeah and they call him who knows yeah
they caught him
they caught him they caught him but it's
definitely a job that really you know
you just stop and buy
you know you're always leaving careful
it's like i said i walk around there
with this look on my face
like i'm gonna kill somebody i like that
you have to because you can't be
yeah hey come kill me yeah i'm so weak
hi
yeah cause that's automatic red flag for
them
you know oh dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] yeah
you know let's get this hoe
but if you walk around and you got that
hammer that you just thump tires with
and you look like you're gonna
crack somebody's skull with it hey man
people won't bother you so they leave
you alone you're stirring your coffee
with a [ __ ] hammer or ice
i'll use my my pocket knife yeah yeah
yeah
the blade clean you know
[Laughter]
what other jobs did you have over the
years anything else that really stood
out yeah before
i ever started driving um i've done a
little bit of everything
i've shoveled some gravel i've worked in
motels i've
gas stations um i've had
all different kinds of just odd
meaningless jobs
it wasn't gonna go nowhere yeah you know
then
they offered me a grant that was free
because i was on
food stamps welfare mm-hmm and uh i was
like yeah well what's the grant consist
about what it what is it she's like
we have to pick up for a high paying
profession something that's in demand
she said you got nursing or trucking and
nursing is an okay thing but yeah
i don't like people being hurt i get too
tender
so well i've always wanted to drive
so she's like well we'll give you five
grand that you don't have to pay back
but you have to graduate you can't fail
yeah i was top 97 of my class that's
awesome yeah yeah i was only girl
that was even like yeah i was only
female and dang
yeah i guess i just think if i'm a
trucker and i see a female come through
i'm gonna holler at her
oh they were so nice the whole the whole
damn class was just
and most of them were black but that i
loved my whole class
i i like all different you know people
so i get along with everybody
would you did they have a fake rig a
simulator you would try it first or no
no
no they gave us these junky little day
cabs that we start off
you know just doing the backing up moves
you know which is alley docking and
straight line backing and
parallel parking which you don't have to
do but
they teach you the basics and then her
own she owned her own two peterbilts
wow and she would let the classmates
take those out with the trainers
trainers would take off we'd get to a
certain spot
then they'd let one of the students do
some driving and we'd all take turns
it'd be like five to a truck
and we'd all take turns and i shifted
like i was in nascar that's cool
yeah well 55 in like five seconds we're
good
yeah and what about uh this might be the
last question i have what about your
first kiss you remember your first kiss
or no
yes i do i was 14 years old
damn girl yeah yeah
who went over heels with the the town
punk
was he what made him a punk kind of what
was that oh he quit school
oh yeah did drugs drinking he was 18 i
was 14.
yeah uh let's see he'd sneak at the bus
stop to meet me my mother
she actually introduced me to him your
mom did yeah
they were both from our lady of peace
yeah but they were
our lady a piece of ass bro well you
know what our lady of peace is
the church right it's a mental uh
hospital oh damn fur
well they changed by the time they got
to our mom had a nervous breakdown
uh the guy went in for drugs they met
well when they met my mother comes out
when she finally got
i guess what you would call normal she
comes out she's like
i met this guy said he knows you and
he's so nice he's so sweet
and he's so good looking well i ended up
meeting the dude
later on down the road when i found out
he was a fruit and you know just
nutty and [ __ ] so he's out there huh
yeah he was bad news
yeah but that was the first kiss he was
damn he was good looking was he yeah
who'd he look like he was dark
complected he had uh
brown eyes brown hair tall thin has six
pack
damn very nice
very nice um his mom and dad
uh was romeo and lee they were really
good people
were their parents names yeah that's
cool names romeo was his dad
lee was his mother and romeo is a dope
name really they had a rapper that kind
of stole it from everybody but i feel
like it should be coming back
i wouldn't mind having a little kid
named romeo
what was your first concert you ever
went to you remember oh yes i do
ozzy osbourne and motley crue damn
that's a good one it was bark
at the moon and uh motley crue shouted
the devil
it was at the old cardinal stadium in
louisville the bush stadium
no no that was before that it was the
cardinal stadium the outdoors do
y'all heard of the yum center and
it's the new stadium that louisville has
built this sit right here
uh yeah that's the that's the old one
right there
because it was outside and the motley
crew and ozzy osbourne concert was
outdoors
in the stadium it was excellent it was
yes and i don't remember a lot of it but
what i do
yeah were y'all on drugs or just
drinking wheat
oh yeah that was i was 14. so i was
pretty green to everything i had never
actually done anything up until i was
14. yeah so first thing i ever tried was
smoking pot and the guy my first
boyfriend what gym i was telling you
about
we went together oh nice my mom and dad
drops us off right
unbelievable and i was all so excited
you know and i saw
uh motley crew i was just you know
stoked and pumped and we're just
jamming you know heads banging and you
know the little thing going on and
you know yeah then the next thing i know
it's like ozzy's on and i was like
you know i'm starting to get like all
foggy head and [ __ ] and can't remember
hardly nothing
you know but every joint that he had
brought had been smoked
so yeah yeah we were pretty toasty
and i remember being up against the
fence oh i bet huh like me and him
sitting in the grass
oh okay and it's pitch black outside and
i guess we was waiting for my mom and
dad picks up that's why i guess we were
there
oh yeah i bet i bet that but did i
remember being in the car shortly after
and my dad always claimed that he was
the one that could bust us if we'd been
smoking pot right and he couldn't
[ __ ] no my mom knew it every time she
was the one that didn't smoke i found
out later that my dad was the one that
smoked yeah
you're too high to know that we're high
sober when it can tell
[Laughter]
dude i remember i went to green day
concert one time i was so high
that i i watched the opening band
and i thought that was green day i sang
all the green days songs
you did 100 i sang every green day song
that i knew
i heard it as they played it i thought
it was green day
it's over i'm ready to leave ask my
friends are we ready to go
and then like green day hasn't even
performed yet and it might
who was you jamming to in your own head
i mean besides it being green day who is
actually playing
i don't know you want to look it up
green day tour 1994
1995 maybe i don't know
but damn they were good man i was doing
some kind of something with hallucinogen
in it
oh dude i never it could have been
beethoven playing anything since
green day
yeah this is good jam man i'll tell you
this one too so
at another can you see who their opener
was maybe if you see their tour history
maybe would that be it or i'm not sure
yeah
there you go uh green day tour should
maybe be on there
20 yeah let's do 95 maybe
see if they played new orleans it
doesn't say their opener though does it
yep that was it right there december 6
dude
well other acts the riverdales dude
i don't know who they were but they
sound just like they were just doing
covers of green day i think
the riverdale riverdale's okay
all righty then
man they were real good and then here
was the worst part another time i went
to
some concert and i remember being high
somebody laced a joint or just laced
with me
i think the lord just laid there done
and uh
and damn man i hit a damn uh
i uh i got so high i remember thinking i
was a raccoon for a couple minutes
and i found this man at the back of the
thing i was feeling on his chest and i
thought he was in a uh
in the war and it was a cop he had like
a badge on i remember feeling the badge
like you were you in the war you know i
thought it was like a medal or something
you know
and he's like i'm a [ __ ] cop man you
know
you need to take this [ __ ] into the
bathroom i was like i think i'm dying he
goes
well you need to [ __ ] go die in the
bathroom son he didn't care
he said you need to go [ __ ] die here
i mean i've been feeling on his damn
chest i don't blame him really
but i was like i couldn't see i thought
i was a raccoon i'm glad i didn't tell
him i thought i was a raccoon
because yeah he probably would have put
a straight jacket on your ass
i don't think people want to hear that
you know
but yeah it was fun going to concerts
man did you ever up to annie on drugs
you ever got lsd was popular back then i
don't like it
i actually tried it just twice and only
did a half a hit each time i tried it
and i didn't like it
yeah it it's just it's weird things
happen and it wasn't that i was tripping
it was just something that
odd uh it's in the middle of summertime
first time i tried it half a hit and
it's it's hot and i'm standing on my
friend's porch and i look down and
just this random dog walks in front of
me and barfs but as he's barfing he's
backing up
and it's just kind of long getting out
of his mouth and i'm like what the [ __ ]
you know what is this you know i just
didn't care for that then the second
time i tried it with my brother
and a friend of our staff oh wow it was
just a half time
yeah and we're driving down the road
we're in shepherdsville and we're coming
around the corner where the stockyards
are
and we saw this line of traffic ahead of
us
that's coming toward us and we're like
what the hell and we saw
this
there's a guy on this horse is running
full speed
coming toward us in the now we're on
acid
okay damn and there's a horse that's
holding up all his traffic
that's huge well as he's running full
gallop he's running
to us it looks like the legs are
flailing off like this as the horse is
right
we're all three laughing so damn hard
that we can't drive so we actually had
to pull over
and sit there until we could catch our
breath run the snot off our nose in the
eyes
and we're like what the hell was we just
looking at was that
a guy on a horse what the hell is that
and it just how how do you pick two
times that you see a dog vomit
and a guy on a horse in the middle of
the [ __ ] road
look look rolling full speed there ain't
no cart back there he's just a little
like he's at the kentucky derby you know
on the interstate
it's like what the hell yeah that's god
right there i'm telling you this because
i remember one time being high on
mushrooms or something and
being went to the gas station and all
the ground just suddenly all these
little pieces of oil look like they
started running around everywhere
and i'm like oh my god is that roaches
what is this you know it's just insane
and then we go inside and the guy said
as we're leaving i swear to god he goes
uh y'all be a little conscious by the
pumps there's uh we got a roach
infestation by the pumps and i'm like
and i'm just thinking when have i when
has there ever been a roaches by a gas
pump
ever maybe one you see one every now and
then but like a roach infestation
just sometimes weird [ __ ] happens when
you're on drugs and you just it doesn't
you're like damn this makes things
making flakka or something
yeah it could have been it's like they
made something so much weirder
but a dog barfing that would [ __ ]
lose my mind man if you had advice or
suggestions for any women who were
thinking about that getting into the
trucking business or anything like that
was there any
any suggestions you'd offer to them yes
um get plenty of sleep don't let the job
run your life you are the captain of
your own ship
you know you when you are tired stop
you know if you want to shower take a
shower you know
it's it those kinds of things you know
you want to you want to do your job you
want to be out there on time
but you also want to stay human and be
able to function
because if you can't then you don't need
to be driving
and a lot of times you're getting pushed
to get there do this one do this one do
this one you ain't done yet you ain't
done that oh by the way you need to go
here you're gonna go there
and it's like no i have to sleep yeah i
have to have a shower
i gotta get something to eat you know
you can't ignore it
or if you ignore yourself you can't
drive it's just not worth it
and it ain't safe yeah it's interesting
you say that man some of the same things
in my own life right now just been
realizing i got to do more taking care
of myself you know
plus you want to find a job that you
actually like doing
you don't want to stay stuck driving and
hate it because it ain't for you if you
hate it
you know and you have to you have to
keep your head
turned all the time and watch behind
your back
you know i think if you help people that
eventually it'll come around to you
eventually sometime or another yeah
but karma is kind of cool to sit and
watch if you just be patient let it
happen
that's one cool thing i like about i
feel sorry when people die young and
sometimes
they die early in their life because
they don't get to life really does have
that full karma effect really
in a lot of ways you get to see things
come back around and you're like oh wow
when you see somebody cut you off the
ultimate on the road
you know this is like the prize winner
the big chicken dinner
if you see somebody cut you off or cut
somebody
else off and then immediately following
is these blue lights flying after that
person yeah then you can sit there in
that truck
and laugh your ass off and point your
finger
and just be like as you go down the road
yeah that's that's the revenge that's
the ultimate sweet revenge right there
i like that yeah uh ginger thank you so
much for being here with us
oh you're welcome we really appreciate
it and uh thanks for asking me
yeah it's really it's an honor and it's
just cool to learn about the business
and
and hear about some of the you know pros
and cons of it and
and just to see a woman out there
working hard getting it done busting
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine
that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
[Music]
hands
just